what we like to do to stay fit a well  looks like all that shimmying has paid  off for model Charlotte McKinney  check out the 23 year old super fit and  fabulous bikini body Charlotte hit the  beach Saturday in Santa Monica and  totally turned heads in this skimpy  two-piece yeah that's a whole lot of leg  a whole lot of abs and a whole lot of  cleavage we're gonna push the envelope  with the outfit the former Dancing with  the Stars contestant even had a mini  photo shoot she goes did this sexy shot  to Instagram yeah go ahead and stare she  really is just that hot it's crazy but I  think it's good it's hardly the first  time we've seen Charlotte flaunt her  physique she got her big break in a 2015  Carl's jr. Superbowl commercial and  regularly shows off her assets on  Instagram